I screwed online last night and there's  this one gift so funny wait wait wait /  gif yeah dude it's chip what would it be  chip everybody knows it's Jeff it's not  peanutbutter it stands for graphic  interface the guy that created it says  it's chip it isn't he a computer  engineer not an Englishman teacher or  professor or something does he work for  merriam-webster cuz last time I checked  graphics was pronounced with the gun so  he created he could call it whatever he  wants  oh sure he kid that's just like you to  take that side of the yard and you  always got to be right you always got to  be right it's shift graphics graphics  interfere what  all right  yeah  junk it's on  did I check your pretty little best get  it just a little bit such a hurt  [Music]  [Music]  Yeah right  you